no hay aliado más antiguo y leal que
francia con esta contundencia habló el
presidente de eeuu joe biden tras la
reunión con su homólogo francés emmanuel
macrón la primera de ambos mandatarios
desde la crisis de los submarinos del
pasado mes que llevó a francia a retirar
momentáneamente a su embajador en
washington
bardem reconoció este viernes que su
país actuó de forma torpe en esta
situación
guau creo que lo que ocurrió fue para
usar una frase inglesa torpe no se hizo
con muchas gracias
tenía la impresión de que francia había
sido informada mucho antes de que el
acuerdo no se iba a llevar a cabo
sinceramente no sabía que no lo habían
hecho
[Música]
tras alcanzar un acuerdo de construcción
de submarinos nucleares con estados
unidos e inglaterra australia canceló un
contrato previo con francia este viernes
macrón quiso poner énfasis en la
importancia de la reunión y los temas
tratados con su homólogo estadounidense
y en cierto modo se trata de decisiones
muy concretas que apoyan las acciones e
iniciativas conjuntas que estamos
llevando a cabo en diferentes campos y
veo esto como el comienzo de un proceso
de confianza real que estamos
construyendo juntos y que dará lugar a
una cooperación reforzada en estos
puntos
uno de los puntos en los que insiste el
presidente francés es la mayor
independencia europea en materia militar
frente a la otan para macrón es clave el
papel que pueda jugar europa en la
región indo pacífica donde reiteró su
voluntad de cooperar con eeuu pese a que
las dos potencias se han comprometido a
dejar el pasado atrás el presidente
francés mandó una advertencia diciendo
que la confianza es como el amor las
declaraciones son buenas pero las
pruebas son mejores